most people think they're being swindled
that capitalism is swindling them so how
are you trying to change this kind of
idea of corporate culture can capitalism
be an instrument for social good can in
fact capitalism be used to create a more
just economically just but otherwise
socially just happier healthier
sustainable world Paul Julie Jones and I
believe it can and what you have to do
is ask the American public which we've
done what do they think would constitute
just capital and as you heard people
want to be paid fairly they want to be
respected they want to be engaged you
know we lose in the United States 300
billion dollars every year from
disengaged and actively disengaged
people who hate to come to their job
where they hate their jobs come Sunday
they don't want to be there okay but how
do you make sure that companies are
doing more than just paying lip service
to this well did you actually go inside
and check it out from the employees you
know when that every company has a
mission statement but they don't live up
to it and who knows better than people
who work in those companies right how
did you know you know you before this
business to be successful you need
loyalty from three constituency's one is
the employees number one second is
customers and third is investors and all
these three if your employees are happy
and healthy your customers are going to
be healthy oh that's was a healthy I'll
be treated right the messes are going to
be happy okay so debug we have a pie
chart that shows what various people
that you surveyed you know as part of
the launch of just capital what they
think a Reno is an element of corporate
justness justness so sixteen percent
believe paying benefits that makes a lot
of sense I thought it would be hired by
the way fifteen percent satisfaction and
hiring and eleven percent the third
would be products and services impact
what do you think out of those top three
excuse me thirty-eight percent is just
other right like just everything all
come by
every other thing so there's actually a
pretty big constituency of people who
just don't know right so so what do you
think is it going to have the biggest
impact I think employees have to be paid
well and they have to be appreciated
they have to be part of teams where they
emotionally bond where they have a
common shared vision where they
complement strengths while this is known
by the way if your manager ignores you
your rate of disengagement goes up by
forty five percent or if they don't
ignore you but they criticize you you
actually get better twenty percent
because you'd rather beeping engage at
least you're being engaged in notice
even though you're criticized but if
they notice a single strength that you
have the disengagement falls to less
than one percent and health improves so
how do you create an environment that's
more like a sports team you know shared
vision emotional bonding complimenting
strengths the data is there the data is
there for what makes employees feel
relevant so what it's not just being
paid you want to feel relevant right you
want to feel relevant you want to be
engaged so what is just capital exactly
going to do just capital is doing is
doing and has already done surveys of
the American population and then publish
them and create instruments also for
change in the workplace social
engagement physical health so what
provide companies tools provide company
suits instruments so one make the issue
more raise the awareness of this issue
and number to provide companies of tools
when and then publish a list of just
capital one thousand companies okay well
you know you got to start somewhere
right and this is you know raising that
awareness yeah we're starting a
conversation okay and on another note
before you before we go the conversation
you will also want to start relates to
your book right super jeans well super
jeans is written with the Harvard neuro
geneticist Rudy tansy and basically the
new science of epigenetic says that
every experience you have it modulates
the activity of your jeans so
philanthropy for example if it makes you
feel good he turns on the good genes and
turns on the bench you healthier it
makes you help you